là on vient de voir michel piccoli
envers sabine azéma sandrine bonnaire
vos coéquipiers dans ce film c'est un
peu la nostalgie dans un lieu théâtral
sa perte tirée des recherches dans une
sorte de labyrinthe sa fille comme ça se
passait lui le père et et homme de
théâtre ou auteur comédien metteur en
scène et la fille décide après une fugue
danon et le père est complètement
inquiète mort mort ils savent y est
presque perdu qu'est devenue sa fille
pauline on peut être mais tellement hors
normes il s'intéresse beaucoup à lui
même quand même si bien su alors cette
fille par l'intermédiaire des passages
sabine azéma qui est la compagne du père
donne rendez vous à son père au théâtre
à dimanche à minuit parce qu'elle sait
que c'est là qu'elle pourra le trouver
seul et avoir enfin une explication
temps a perdu à tête à tête avant ce
final de lyon mais là une sorte de
psychanalyse sauvage un peu oui il ya
une chose c'est que ce site nous appelle
ça la famille exhibitionniste et rien
plus bouleversants de plus secret de
plus émouvant
le plus troublant que les rapports entre
un père et une fille à des degrés divers
hélas cette fille et ce prêt sont
tellement inquiets et avec totem ou là
c'est tellement heureux de se retrouver
qu'ils mettent en scène leur rencontre
pour savoir qui est le coupable qui est
le fautif comment vont ils se retrouver
la semaine mettent en scène leur retour
et dans ce théâtre le père en profite
pour il a des élèves acura cours de
delhaize actrice et il demande à ses
élèves d'imaginer et de recréer
l'arrivée de mano et manon d'ailleurs va
arriver en secret dans ce lieu de
théâtre et bavois que le père est afin
de mettre en scène son retour
si vous l impression que des métiers
comme metteur en scène par exemple on
peut être le vôtre empêchent parfois
d'avoir des relations vraies plus intime
avec avec ses enfants
on joue certainement très rare sol et
les parents eux les pères qui peuvent
avoir des rapports très très intime avec
leurs parents leurs enfants
c'est un travail de très longue haleine
je vais lorsque sandrine venir dit rien
n'a changé vous avez l'impression que
vous gardez tous là vous voyez les
reportages sur les étudiants vous a
l'impression qu'il ya des choses qu'on
change est quand même dans les rapports
entre enfants et parents
oui je crois que les enfants maintenant
sont beaucoup plus adulte que que les
enfants de ma génération
et beaucoup plus précis est beaucoup
plus sérieux et beaucoup moins un
anarchiste est beaucoup plus inquiète
sérieusement de de leur avenir
il n'y a plus la belle innocence
possible j'en reviens michel piccoli
hector mauvais centres des oscars à qui
vous faites confiance un metteur en
scène de 25 ans oui c'est un peu de
l'avant garde de leurs riches et aux
voeux de l'avant-garde concrètes aussi
il ya une histoire de passion
d'aujourd'hui la puritaine jacques
doillon ses classiques et qui on va vous
retrouver dans la rumba de roger hanin
vous est multicarte
oui c'est exact qu'est-ce qui vous
conduit à faire ses choix successifs ça
c'est le hasard vous avez envie
justement de ne jamais être enfermé dans
un rôle précis ne jamais être enfermé
toujours l'oiseau sur la branche
toujours aux aguets toujours à l'éveil
ils ont toujours un éveil leur doillon
est un déjà un ancien compagnon de route
et de travail
roger hanin est un très vieux compagnon
de route et de travail et carax et et le
nouveau les dans ma vie voilà alors le
fait de faire confiance à nouveau un
jeune 25 ans ça vous oblige vous vous
même à vous recadre essaie de trouver
d'autres réflexes bien sûr savoure
charge vous fait voir le l'art
cinématographique et le monde dans
lequel on vit un peu d'une autre manière
ça vous évite d'avoir nos propres the
year merci michel piccoli démâté notre
invité je m'appelle la puritaine et puis
mauvais sens voilà en ce moment la fiche
enfin à partir de demain